this spider-man news is just getting
crazier broke the internet
just a little bit ago well by the time
we're uploading this we'll see
having major internet problems
spider-man 3 doctor strange confirmed
let's get the report from our friend
warren from cosmic wonder all righty
[Music]
how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel cosmic wonder
and we have some
insane spider-man 3 mcu news today
if it wasn't already crazy enough with
jamie foxx's
electro returning for spider-man 3 in a
different universe
things are now getting even crazier than
before and everything is sort of coming
together now in a very epic way
it has now been officially confirmed
that benedict cumberbatch
is joining the cast for spider-man 3.
wow doctor is going to be helping out
peter parker
the hollywood reporter that is
good and strange doctor has been caught
in the spider's web
benedict cumberbatch is putting on the
cloak of levitation and will reprise
marvel's supernatural hero doctor
strange for the latest spider-man
movie installment starring tom holland
this is so cool
[Laughter]
i can't wait occupied by robert downey
jr who played tony stark slash iron man
and spider-man homecoming great show
this will just make more sense to hop
between all might i want to say that
this gives peter parker a father figure
and gives the movie
extra star power while also tying them
to the greater
marvel cinematic universe so this pretty
much confirms that doctor strange is
going to bring the multiverse to
spider-man 3. we've already expected it
with the confirmation yeah of course
jamie foxx's electro is going to be in
spider-man
rumors going around that kirsten dunst
and others from different
universes not in the mc were going to be
reprising their roles as well
and now we have a very clear answer of
just how this
is all happening it's going to be doctor
strange that brings everybody into
spider-man 3. and as far as we're
concerned this is going to be the first
movie where the multiverse is really
opened up in one division they're going
to sort of explore this with her
creating alternate realities but it's
very what is your plan marvel
you have a crazy plan
[Music]
oh my goodness sadness it looks like
spider-man 3 is what's going to throw
the multiverse into madness
when we end spider-man 3 things are most
likely going to be very
very crazy and that's going to lead us
into doctor strange 2 where doctor
strange has to fix
the multiverse that was thrown into
balance in spider-man 3.
now this really opens up
definitely opens up sounds so cool
spider-man toby mcguire and andrew
garfield spider-man
all in one movement how sexy they are
doing this for a while but now that the
good
doctor has joined spider-man 3 chances
of this happening have just increased
exponentially so doctor strange
is confirmed to be in spider-man 3. what
do you hope
my pulse is literally
let me know what crazy insane things you
would like to see in the comments down
below don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest
mcu videos so you can enter this week's
giveaway for a chance to win a loki
funko pop for live updates you can
follow me on instagram and as always
thank you all so much for watching
there's only one piece of this news
that's i'm like i don't really know how
i feel about that but everything else
bring it we gotta talk we gotta talk
thanks for putting that together man
this just makes perfect
like oh god i need to get my thoughts in
order it's okay
calm ourselves there's a lot coming into
the universe it's like a weird
i've as i was watching this i felt my
heart rate like going up
and then it's like my body just like
froze
and then my heart was just beating it
was like this
weird feeling because what what marvel's
doing i think is so
neat i think it's so impressive how
they're handling this because
after coming off of end game you're like
how can you get any bigger or crazier
than that everyone's had their theories
and things you could pull from the
comics in terms of you know
multi-dimensional traveling or
you know cosmo stuff but this plan
that they're doing just gets me super
excited
doctor strange going in here allowing
for a perfect linear segue into
multiverse of madness having to fix up
whatever conundrums occurred from the
events
in spider-man sound very exciting to me
keep in mind like this is mcu so
there's one version of me that's like i
don't want doctor strange to outshine
peter parker in his own movie there
already seems to be so many other things
that could potentially
outshine tom holland in his own part
three
of this spider-man franchise him having
another mentor figure
i feel like some fans might get to the
point of hearing news like that of
aren't we kind of sick of hearing about
peter needing a father figure again a
father mentor figure one more time
especially in this mcu thing but for the
situation that he's in for the
cliffhanger that was set up from far
from home
it would make sense that he would
probably need some additional help right
here
there's been a lot of theories going
around but this seems to be confirmed
news right these things of like
multi-dimensional like having an
electro come into the fold and then
whoever else might spring from that
it only makes sense to have doctor
strange come in here now this whole
father figure mentor thing
i feel like is more likely to be
believed you know after having that you
know
little bits of great interaction that we
got in infinity war between the two of
them but
our hero names yeah then having the the
events after infinity war
i feel like doctor strange would
probably have to be much more of a
screen presence as opposed to what tony
stark was
in homecoming because in that film he
only had like eight minutes of screen
time i believe this particular situation
that peter parker's finding himself in
doctor strange has to be in
it throughout a good chunk of the movie
to say the least
and that would only better explain his
ability to go
through multiverse traveling uh
shenanigans man
and i just like the idea of benedict
cumberbatch and tom holland
having a lot more on-screen time
together that just really excites me as
these two characters
that just sounds like a great great
great
time the plan of what phase four is is
what's exciting me the most
you have this thing with eternals going
on which i'm sure in some way can open
up the door from all this other stuff
that they're doing
but from one division multiverse of
madness what they're doing with
spider-man 3.
my hope though is that it doesn't get
too caught up in mcu
setting up stuff and still manages to be
a pure spider-man movie at its heart at
its core
that it can remain a solid spider-man
film because right now
it has the potential to get lost and all
this other craziness
as opposed to feeling like a perfect you
know peter parker installment that being
said you know it's the mcu i'm excited
for whatever craziness they throw at the
wall on this one and i hope they go
crazy with this
yeah well that seems like part of the
fun that they're embracing moving
forward
is adding more just things that you
would describe as being sort of crazy
for the mcu and yeah i found myself
teetering back and forth with the idea
during the video and then i thought
the theme you know they have the
recurrent home titles and they also have
yeah this
recurrent theme of the mentors who have
taken you know the place in helping
shape peter in the absence of uncle ben
and whatnot and so yeah i it makes a lot
of sense to me because yeah they're
talking about all this multiverse stuff
doctor strange is the perfect guy
to go and deal with that but he also
does seem like kind of the perfect
avenger to further develop
by giving him a mentee i feel like yeah
if they handle it the right way and they
don't make it
that doctor strange takes up all the
focus that could be something that
enhances both characters because i think
one thing people do complain about
doctor strange for
also is that he could be a more you know
fleshed and
intimate character that we get to know
better and i feel like peter
could be a great conduit for that and
also
given the problem peter has found
himself in with
you know being revealed and having this
j jonah jameson and
you know obviously inklings of a
multiverse opening up again it feels
like doctor strange
is the guy to come help with that yeah
you know like because peter can't deal
with this on its own this sounds
like an awesome plan moving forward and
that's the fun
is to me seeing how they are rising to
that challenge of how do we make things
bigger and more engaging after end game
but
not just going it's even more grim and
bigger stakes it seems like they're kind
of pivoting and going
well how much further can we expand the
imagination
of the mcu and that's what this gets me
excited for
yeah and then the idea too that like
let's face it
this the spider verse is like this close
to being confirmed to be
segued and connected perfectly into the
mcu if you already got a lecture
confirmed you got j jones and jameson
back
it's only a matter of time before we
hear about that little andrew garfield
toby mcguire crossover
we're we're this close to getting there
i can't wait for that i really can't
there's something that feels like
nostalgic to me about having
doctor strange appearing here and then
having
sam raimi direct the dr strange movie
especially if we do get to the point
with the spider-man 3
where we do get you know kirsten dunst
to return someone from the raimi trilogy
to return in here either way
raymie kicked off the live-action
spider-man so there's something that
feels like appropriately nostalgic
about having sam raymond direct
multiverse of madness
after a spider-man movie comes out i'm
overwhelmed by the information it sounds
it sounds amazing to me it really does
yeah it really does like
the only thing that sounds a tad
off-putting is
another mcu character being like father
figure to
uh to peter parker at this point i'm not
sure why
maybe he's cause i'm at the point where
i'm like just let him be his own person
you know
but for what the stakes call for for
what the situation calls for
he needs a mentor in this type of
debacle he does he does it just makes
sense that he wouldn't he can't just go
through the universes
with no guidance you know i feel like
they could maybe
access different dimensions of having a
mentor figure so that it maybe doesn't
feel as on the noses
each movie needs one of these but yeah
like if there's a way to
stretch that nuance out i feel like it
would work in a way that isn't like okay
i get it you guys he's still a kid so
you know we'll we'll see either way
whatever crazy plans they have for this
bottom line consensus of it
is i'm excited and i still want this to
feel like a peter parker movie at heart
then also you know go bat [ __ ] on this
one
spider-man home is where the heart is
too long of a title it's islam guys what
do you think about this news subscribe
to the real rejects click that
notification bell
holy crap this is um like i have this
weird euphoric
it's a calm bliss about it it's a
strange feeling this is the best
doctor strange feeling last but not
least
i like to shout out a man today named
flev doran
flev my dude you've been part of our
patreon for such a long time you've now
made it to the patron of the day
shout out tear with that in mind we're
going traditional
f stands for fun
absolutely and l stands for
lovely predictable it is
e stands for eloquent because you're one
hell of a communicator
and v stands for virginal because you
are
pure as the driven snow thanks for being
here fleb
you rock my door and okay